So to summarize the Tornado features, it's an object oriented design,
which promotes scalability. The idea of cluster objects in the proce, protected
procedure call is mainly with a view to preserving locality,
while ensuring concurrency. And we also saw how reference
counting is used in the implementation of the objects
so that, you don't have to have hierarchical locking of objects. And the locus
of locks held by an object is confined to itself. And doesn't span
across objects, or its replicas. That's very
important, because that's what promotes concurrency, and
that also means that careful management is
needed of the reference count mechanism to
provide existence guarantee and garbage collection of objects
based on reference counts. And multiple implementation are possible
for the same operating system object. Now for
instance, you may have a low-overhead version when scalability
is not important. And then you might decide
to know this particular operating system object I am
experiencing a lot of contention for this. I
want to go for a more scalable implementation of
this particular operating system object. So, this
is where incremental optimization and dynamic adaptation of
the implementation of objects comes into play
and the other important principle that is used
in Tornado is optimizing the common case.
I mentioned that when we talked about page-fall
handling, that is something that happens quite often.
On the other hand, destroying a portion of
the address based because the application does not
need it any more, that is called region
destruction. That happens fairly infrequently, so if it
takes more time, that's okay So that's where the
principle of optimizing the common case comes in.
And no hierarchical locking through the reference counting
mechanism. And limiting the sharing of operating system
data structures by replicating critical data structures and managing
the replicas under the covers is a creep
up property in Tornado to promote scalability and concurrency.